mais créer une société peut se révéler
compliquée surtout quand on est isolé
attrape la pépinière d'entreprise
Crisalide est là pour apporter conseils
et réseau professionnels aux jeunes
entrepreneurs notre rôle c'est de leur
être directement utile en leur proposant
donc des locaux euh des services
d'accueil et des
animations comment vendre son projet de
financement c'est le thème de cet
atelier se jeunes entrepreneurs sont
venus comprendre comment nouer un bon
contact avec les banques là on a entendu
le point de vue de la CCI et d'une
banque qui explique comment eux
risonnent de façon tout à fait
neutre donc on était un peu dans leur
tête ici à trappe en tout cas ou dans
les Yvelines on est bien accompagné à la
Maison de l'Entreprise il y a la CCI à
la pépiniire également qui nous
accompagne pour nous aider à mieux
mettre en place notre dossier de
financement s nous disent non c'est pas
forcément pour être déplaisant mais
c'est aussi parce que s'ils disent non
on a peut-être intérêt à à reconsidérer
l'investissement partenaire de
crisealide la Chambre de commerce des
Yvelines est aussi présente pour des
accompagnements individuels l'objectif
les aider à vendre leur projet les clés
à respecter c'est effectivement être
présenter un bon dossier donc bien
parler du projet bien parler au-delà des
chiffres au-delà de l' analyse
financière démontrer que le projet va
être viable dans
près de 100 entreprises ont été
accompagnées depuis l'ouverture du site
en 2007 et le résultat est concluant 80
% d'entre elles il dépassent les 5 ans
d'activité contre 50 % pour la moyenne
nationale